all i ever wanted in this world
is carnage
tom you know when it comes to your
performance of eddie and venom what did
you get to try in this film that you
didn't get to try on the first venom
about 10 000 more lines for venom for a
start yeah there you go there you go um
i think fundamentally it was um
it was being able to implement some of
the infrastructure and the sandbox of
where where
where eddie and venom could maneuver
through and beginning middle and an end
and to to carve a journey uh to then
to then play with latchley to develop
the character further because we
established in the first uh eddie and
venom meet and here they are
and now the second was very much about
how much relationship exercise can we
lay down
whilst having to follow a dynamic plot
to you know which is a ride that how
much pull and push can we have between
the between the guys you know you know
speaking of that that uh that tug and
pull you know andy uh you played very
famously the character gullum in the
lord of the rings films like venom that
was also a character wrestling with
these dual personalities so what was it
like for you to direct someone else
doing that um
tom really kind of owned that character
you know so fully and just watching i
just literally i didn't have to do very
much to be honest i i was there to sort
of safeguard other things and and to
sort of see the whole but i
i mean tom runs runs the floor when when
he's playing venom and eddie because
he's such a brilliant so noisy
so
you know tom's process is it's just like
he's so self-sufficient i mean and just
brilliant it was just it was just i i
just literally had to to make sure that
i could frame it in an interesting way
and and and then when when required sort
of
allow the the shots to make a physical
version of venom uh you know interesting
i suppose but but but the whole kind of
well we had fun also evolving the the
emotional arc of them and and when and
that fight i mean that was an organic
thing actually when when
you kind of have that the big bust up um
we have to unpack the um the pragmatics
of it is like you get the ingredients
it's like well how are we going to fit
the room right and how we're going to
look at this and now what how can we
optimize the most the most from it you
know exactly does he describe i should
be sort of shouting myself a lot you
know with that in the corner trying to
figure out how it's going to sound but
then deploying it into into a scene and
figuring it figuring out the jigsaw as
you go along yeah yeah yeah you know
it's a
it's an interesting communicator isn't
it yeah really right how do we wrestle
this alligator into a bathtub you know
you know tom you you share a story
credit on this film you're also a
producer you know what's so much
invested now in this franchise is it
your intention to sort of embrace this
kind of larger spider-man multiverse
that's blossoming and have venom be in
these bigger crossover movies now that
you've really perfected playing him
and there's two there's two answers
there that are immediate
both reactionary
um i think one would be remiss as a
producer not to look at the long league
you know and say hey you know
there are there's
there are opportunities here uh the
woman needs to consider very seriously
because we have all the uh the
capabilities
and um
and the department
the departments that can take care of
all of the cross-checking to make sure
and ensure that certain things can and
could happen in the future with regards
possibilities regards this ip invoke
commerce
so yeah you know and the other the other
part of me is just so invested in
enjoying playing and enjoying my time
should it be the last movie today you
know uh and venom two is the last of it
that up until this point i immerse
myself as much in the bed of it and
enjoyed every single relationship within
it in in creating what i think is you
know a much stronger movie than the
first and then a step forward again with
it so i'm just really enjoying playing
eddie and venom and being with my team
you know so there's there's long long
wish fulfillment and conceptuals which
which cater for team and for you know
crossovers in universes you know yeah i
care about and then i would be i would
be remiss not to and i'd absolutely want
to get involved in that 100 100
but i'm also really happy with where
we're at you know and we're getting to
do something we did it and you know and
and that that's brilliant so i'm pleased
with for sure you know
for sure that's awesome you know andy
this film is is 85 minutes it's probably
one of the shortest comic book movies
that we've seen it's lean and mean i
love that about it uh was that always
the intention to sort of keep it lean
and mean or was there a lot of stuff
that we haven't that that you cut out
that maybe you'll you'll add on to like
a dvd or or something like that down the
road we always we always set out to make
a very fast-paced movie um that you know
that had had the energy and the kind of
that was that that both you know was
sort of muscular and and had the breadth
and time to examine the evolving
relationship between eddie and venom and
that the emotional storyline kind of
went through but the actual story itself
is a very as you would have seen a very
quite simple storyline but it but but it
moves uh it's just like the you know the
events kind of unfold and and the
emergence of carnage is such a it's such
a whirlwind that that's that was the
speed that was the sort of the tempo
that we wanted to work out and we always
said you know it's going to be a 90
minute movie it's going to be you know
it's going to be around and we very we
didn't drift from there
yeah a roller coaster we just wanted it
to be a kind of and and you know with
the way that the story lines break up
and depart and then come back together
and and the relationships break up and
come back together you know it all felt
very metronomic in a way and and and and
yet i don't think we've i don't think
you'd want to hang around too much more
because it because it it needed that
that thrill ride yeah yeah and certainly
not in this event i mean you you if you
had a different context in a tv series
or whatever of course you go lateral
there's so much there's a there's an
embarrassment of riches to mine
in in the iep
we had to take
you know take note of what the audience
feedback was from the first one you know
what there are certain elements that
people enjoy that they expect you know
go okay
part of that is like you want
entertaining you know and you want to
sit down and want to
get back and watch something that's
going to happen and be in and you know
be fulfilling
and so but also like you say we take
care of our characters as well so it
fulfills on the lateral as well as an
experiential so you can't go that was
good
well i didn't kill him you know i need
to kill too much of my time i could go
and watch that again or do you mean it's
it's it's a movie to be enjoyed and and
i think you know um hopefully
obviously the big screen's open and
allows you to see it as a movie
experience because i think it's one of
those ones that is a joy to watch in big
in a big theater
that's mine
it's yours and what's yours
it's mine so in this film you play a
serial killer who drives around in a red
convertible he gets into trouble with
his lover uh i couldn't help but get
natural-born killer vibes uh from this
role did you channel that performance or
were you inspired by it in any way while
playing cletus well i wasn't really
thinking of uh
i guess that's mickey knox uh i i wasn't
really thinking of making knocks when i
was
playing cletus
and
you know i watched it for the first time
last night and said but i did i did
thought i thought of that of course
because of the
well
i've only played one other serial killer
but uh i i feel like they're somewhat
distinctive characters hopefully uh you
know you've been part of the hunger
games franchise star wars franchise uh
zombieland franchise i feel like there
should be a white men can't jump
franchise uh that's still ongoing maybe
that that could still happen um but this
is your first marvel movie so like what
was it about venom that brought you to
the marvel
universe
well i mean uh
the lore of the marvel universe i think
is fairly ubiquitous for uh all the
actors uh
you know any anyone would want to be a
part of it i mean why wouldn't you it's
uh
it's its own world and this particular
world is uh enthusiastically
uh
just loved by so many people um and uh
and it's it's incredible and my daughter
is of course you know this is the first
time she's given me any props ever
and
no i shouldn't say that but what my
youngest daughter is an absolute fanatic
about the marvel universe but this
particular uh project i guess the reason
it came to me was because reuben
fleischer directed the first one
and he wanted me to do it uh to to do i
just did a little thing that he played
at the end of the of the first venom
movie
and so i was like well if he wants me in
there and also is i thought it was great
an interesting fascinating
wild character of uh of cletus cassidy
without a doubt you know the marvel
universe is so expansive it continues to
grow they're introducing like
multiverses now with alternate universes
of characters uh are there any other
marvel characters that you'd love to to
see cletus go against that you'd love to
to sort of be opposite
on screen with
i i hadn't thought about that
but i mean
certainly
carnage it seems like it could go
against almost anybody
but
you know it's gonna have to be you know
carnage obviously very evil characters
so
gonna have to be going up against
someone good i suppose you've worked
with andy circus previously as well as a
director you know fans know him really
well for his performances in front of
the camera but what is something unique
that you think he brings to the table as
director when i first met him uh
andy back in uh
i don't know what it was four or five
years ago
uh
i'm not good on dates okay
or just any memory questions eric i'll
be totally forthcoming
anyway
i i when i met him uh
uh i everyone had said this is the
greatest guy in the world literally the
greatest guy in the world so much so
that it was almost annoying you know
like i thought there's no way this guy
can be as great as everyone's saying
then i'm at him i realize all these
people are right and and not only is he
he's got it in a beautiful heart he
really cares
but he is just he's a passionate
capable amazing filmmaker
and i just i had a sense that he would
make something uh
wonderful and and of course he did but i
i i love this guy i think he's one of
the great human beings you have got to
get control of your aggression
we will get hauled off into area 51.
so the way that this is lining up you
are you have two big franchises opening
up one week apart from one another with
venom where you play a villain and then
no time to die where you play a hero so
what is more challenging uh first of all
how does it feel to have two giant
movies like that opening up like one
week apart and then also what's more
challenging playing a villain or playing
a hero um it feels amazing to have these
two roles coming out so close together
it's very very exciting and what i love
about it is that they're so different
you know which i i love you know because
that's what i'm all about playing these
completely different um uh roles and
that's what keeps me excited about being
part of the um industry um and what was
the other question i'm so sorry which
one's more challenging playing a villain
or a hero um
i think it's more challenging playing
the hero
because people have very set ideas about
what a hero should look like whereas
when you're the villain you can
literally be anything so it's like
you're totally free completely liberated
from social norms and that's really
exciting i really enjoyed that
you know you play a character in this
film who has to find her voice because
she hasn't spoken in a very long time as
a performer do you have a time in your
career that you remember sort of really
finding your voice or
do you find your voice sort of over and
over again with each role that you take
on
yeah i think it's a matter of
discovering your voice each time you
take on a role um and i really struggle
with the whole thing of like speaking up
and being seen and you know i i do a lot
of hiding behind
the script and the character you know
that's one of the reasons i think a lot
of people think that actors are
generally like really gregarious and
extrovert kind of people but they're
actually not they're like hiding behind
characters and that's what we love to do
so the you know the thing of finding
your voice yeah i definitely think it's
a process that you need to
learn on each role and in this
particular role in you know playing
shriek and venom it was a very
complicated journey because she does
have such a weird voice and she has it
because she spent all this time in
isolation so it was a matter of working
with my um vocal coach uh tim monak and
uh he helped me find a way to do her
voice but also sustain it throughout the
film without damaging my vocal chords
you know also you're working the
opposite woody harrelson you know and
i know that your first big hollywood
movie woody was in there uh and and also
what he has a film called natural born
killers that kind of reminds me in terms
of a bit of a psycho romance so you know
in terms of finding that chemistry uh
and two people kind of falling for each
other amidst this uh sort of mental
hospital scenario did you what did you
do with woody and was it cool kind of
reuniting with him again after all this
time oh my god it was amazing reunited
with reuniting with him and and i do
think that um that there's a special
connection between you know uh cletus
and uh shriek because it's like they
complete each other so when they're
separated they're almost half of the of
the person and then when they come
together it's like dynamite you know
they just become a heightened version of
themselves and there's something really
really special about that and i feel
like that working with woody just
generally like he's just literally
i just love working with that man so so
much he makes everything so fun and he's
so free and liberated that it makes you
as a performer really free and liberated
and you know the main thing about
i think about performing is like don't
be inhibited inhibited like just be
willing to fall flat on your face and
make mistakes and make a complete fool
of yourself and you see you have to have
a great deal of humility in that respect
as well and woody is like the master of
that and so because he's just willing to
go there um
it challenges me to do the same so i
feel like he makes me a better performer
ready
you feel like home to me
like family
oh wow you could just say i'm happy for
you that was going to be us hey i'm
happy for you